veamos esta reacción ha sido base el
agua va a funcionar como nuestra base y
se va a llevar un protón de nuestro
ácido genérico h
así es que un par de electrones libres
del oxígeno se va a llevar este protón
del hidrógeno dejando los electrones de
este enlace en la a así es que ahora
este oxígeno el oxígeno está enlazado
con tres hidrógenos tres hidrógenos ok
se quedó con un protón extra y entonces
tiene una carga formal positiva y bueno
de hecho podemos seguir el recorrido de
los electrones ok este par de electrones
libres llegan y se llevan a este protón
de aquí formando este enlace de aquí y
por lo tanto formando hidronew h tres o
más y por otro lado estos electrones de
aquí se van a quedar en el a formando a
menos
ok vamos a dibujar por aquí
con su nuevo par de electrones libres
que hacen que tenga una carga formal
negativa bueno y ahora vamos a analizar
qué sucedió porque teníamos aquí nuestro
ácido genérico
h pero donó uno de sus protones por lo
cual a h es nuestro ácido the browns de
dolor y gray ha sido de brawn usted lo
lee y una vez que nuestro ácido dona su
protón se convierte en la base conjugada
a menos por otro lado el agua aceptó un
protón por lo tanto es nuestra base de
browns de dolor y gray y una vez que
nuestra base acepta uno de los protones
se convierte en el ácido conjugado h
tres o más porque entonces nuestra
molécula de idron ya es el ácido
conjugado y a menos es la base conjugada
y bueno si nos ponemos a pensar en la
reacción inversa por ejemplo si el hidro
no le dan a uno de sus protones aa -
entonces lo que obtenemos es
y h ahora una vez que esta reacción
alcance el equilibrio podemos encontrar
la expresión de constante de equilibrio
aunque ahora vamos a pensar en estos
como si fueran los reactivos de activos
en estos como si fueran los productos
pero ductos o sea que estamos pensando
en la reacción directa así es que pues
vamos a encontrar una expresión para la
constante de equilibrio acá a ok aunque
acá se le conoce más bien como la
constante de ionización ácida constante
de ionización
ácida o también se le conoce como la
constante de disociación ácida y la
constante de disociación ácida y sabemos
que cuando estamos escribiendo la
expresión de equilibrio lo que hacemos
es poner la concentración de los
productos arriba y la concentración de
los reactivos abajo aunque por aquí
arriba tenemos y verón yo así es que
vamos a poner por aquí la concentración
de h3 o más la concentración de
hidrógeno por la concentración de a
menos
a menos y tenemos que dividir entre la
concentración de nuestro ácido genérico
la concentración de h
por la concentración de agua pero en
realidad no vamos a poner la
concentración del agua porque el agua es
un líquido puro y su concentración no
cambia entonces vamos a dejar el agua
afuera de la ecuación si es que ya
tenemos aquí nuestra constante de
ionización ácida y pues vamos a ver qué
sucede con un ácido muy fuerte
el ácido clorhídrico hcl va a funcionar
como un ácido de brawn exterior y iba a
donarle un protón al agua que va a
funcionar como nuestra base de bronx de
dolor y así es que podemos pensar que un
par de electrones libres del oxígeno
llega y se lleva el protón de este
hidrógeno dejando los electrones de este
enlace en el cloro y entonces este
oxígeno está enlazado con tres
hidrógenos
tres hidrógenos porque se llevó un
protón por lo cual tiene una carga
formal positiva más 1 otra vez vamos a
seguir paso por paso por donde se
quedaron los electrones
empezamos por aquí con nuestro par de
electrones libres van y toman este
protón formando este enlace y por lo
tanto formando una molécula de idron yo
h3o más y al mismo tiempo estos
electrones de este enlace se quedan en
el cloro aunque entonces tenemos un
cloro con todos los pares de electrones
libres que ya tenía más ese nuevo par de
electrones libres ok se acaba de formar
una unión cloruro que tiene una carga
negativa -1 ahora otra forma de expresar
esta reacción ha sido base la tenemos
por aquí porque es simplemente escribir
h 2 o más
hcl que se transforma en h 3
más más
l menos no creí es una forma mucho más
fácil de expresarla y hcl el ácido
clorhídrico es un ácido súper fuerte y
los ácidos fuertes donan protones muy
fácilmente entonces esto que acabamos de
ver aquí este proceso sucede el 100 por
ciento de las veces que tengamos estos
reactivos así es que tenemos
aproximadamente el 100 por ciento de
ionización el equilibrio está tan
cargado hacia la derecha porque casi
siempre que tengamos estos dos reactivos
va a suceder la reacción que por aquí
simplemente dibujamos la flecha hacia la
derecha en lugar de dibujar la flecha de
las reacciones reversibles porque hay
entonces tenemos un 100% de ionización
así es que todo se convierte en nuestros
productos y bueno escribamos nuestra
expresión de equilibrio la constante de
ionización ácida es igual
la concentración de nuestros productos
multiplicándose sea la concentración del
hidrógeno
por la concentración del unión cloruro
entre la concentración de hcl ácido
clorhídrico y no ponemos la
concentración del agua porque es un
líquido puro ahora analizando qué
constante de ionización ácida nos va a
quedar si tomamos en cuenta que tenemos
el 100 por ciento de ionización entonces
en el equilibrio vamos a tener casi
puros productos así es que estas dos
concentraciones van a ser muy grandes y
muy grandes
porque vamos a tener muchísimos de estos
productos vamos a tener casi puros de
estos productos mientras que casi no
vamos a tener reactivos entonces su
concentración va a ser muy pequeña
muy pequeña
y si pensamos en qué es lo que esto
provoca pues lo que provoca es que la
constante que sea muy grande porque
tenemos un numerador grande y un
denominador muy pequeño que hace que el
número se vuelva todavía más grande así
es que acá
es mucho mucho más grande que 1 y así es
como reconocemos a los ácidos fuertes
ahora pensemos en las bases con jugadas
marcar y regresemos por aquí tenemos
nuestro ácido hcl
y suba se conjugaba sl - ok
este es nuestro par conjugado ha sido
base y entre más fuerte sea un ácido más
débil es la base con jugada y viceversa
ahora como hcl es un ácido muy fuerte
entonces cl - es una base muy débil y
vamos a escribirlo por aquí
entre más fuerte es un nacido gay entre
más fuerte es un nacido más débil es su
base con jugada más débil es su base con
jugada
ahora en esta reacción podemos comparar
la fuerza de las bases por aquí tenemos
una base de browns de dolor y el agua
está funcionando como nuestra base de
bronx de dolor y aceptando un protón y
luego para la reacción inversa por aquí
la base sería el a nyon cloruro que
estaría tratando de quedarse con un
protón del libro nio gray para formar la
reacción inversa
ahora como hcl es buenísimo donando
protones esto significa que el año cl -
no es muy bueno aceptando protones entre
más fuerte sea un nacido más débil es su
base conjugada y por lo tanto el agua es
una base mucho más fuerte que el avión
cloruro bueno ahora vamos a ver otro
ejemplo
finalmente vamos a analizar qué pasa con
el ácido acético
este es nuestro ácido de brown flor y el
ácido acético y este es nuestro protón a
cívico el agua va a ser nuestra base de
bronx de dolor y y un par de electrones
del oxígeno van a llegar y se van a
llevar a este protón y entonces estos
electrones se van a quedar en el oxígeno
así es que pues vamos a dibujar por aquí
nuestros productos aquí se va a formar
el avión aceptado tenemos aquí se h 3
con ese doble enlace con oxígeno
y oxígeno con otro par de electrones
libres y una carga negativa veamos cómo
se mueven los electrones por aquí estos
electrones de este enlace se quedan en
el oxígeno formando este par de
electrones libres y dándole una carga
formal negativa
aunque aquí me había faltado poner otro
par de electrones libres ahora también
vamos a formar y drone yo lo que hoy
tenemos aquí nuestro oxígeno que está
enlazado con tres hidrógenos
y tiene una carga formal positiva h 3 o
más este par de electrones libres llegan
y se llevan al protón a cívico el protón
a cívico y ahora forman este enlace
formando una molécula de idron eo ahora
por otro lado una forma más sencilla de
expresar esta reacción es simplemente
poner el ácido acético de esta forma se
h3c
h ácido acético más h2o nos da el anillo
acetato que es de h3c o o menos más
hidronew que es h 3 o más ahora el ácido
acético es un ácido débil y los ácidos
débiles no donan protones muy fácilmente
así es que este ácido acético va a
mantenerse pro tornado la mayor parte
del tiempo así es que si pensamos en que
esta reacción en algún momento llega a
un
v equilibrio en general va a haber
muchas moléculas de estas de ácido
acético vamos a terminar con una
concentración bastante alta de nuestros
reactivos cuando escribamos nuestra
expresión de equilibrio acá
es igual a la concentración de nuestros
productos o sea la concentración de la
unión acetato
de h3c o o menos por la concentración
del libro nio h 3 o más entre la
concentración del ácido acético porque
no vamos a poner la concentración del
agua entonces ponemos por aquí la
concentración desde h3c
h y en esta reacción el equilibrio está
hacia la izquierda porque el ácido
acético no es muy bueno donando este
protón entonces vamos a tener muchas de
estas moléculas vamos a tener una
concentración muy alta de ácido acético
una concentración muy alta de nuestros
reactivos y entonces el denominador va a
ser muy grande y por lo tanto la
constante va a ser pequeña porque vamos
a tener un número muy grande
grande en el denominador
y vamos a tener pocos productos vamos a
tener un numerador pequeño
qué año y un número pequeño entre un
número grande nos da un número muy
pequeño y entonces nos queda un valor de
que hay una constante de ionización
ácida mucho más pequeña que uno y esa es
una forma de reconocer un ácido débil y
observar su valor de caja